Riot might finally remove all the
toxicity from your boundary matches
happening
bags coming up coming up to the end as
well in their latest Dev diary they
announced that they're working on new
tools to help remove disruptive behavior
across Voice and text chat Team
Deathmatch is also coming to Valerie and
I can't think of literally anyone who
asked for this normal Deathmatch doesn't
even work properly but hey new content
is cool I guess if there was no
objective in valora and the attackers
just had to go and hunt down the
Defenders what a [__] dumb game that
would be Riot also mentioned that their
new in-game tournament mode Premiere
will be coming sometime this year so far
Brazil is the only region that has tried
it but hopefully it comes soon because
ranked is pretty awful right now
especially in High ELO they also said
that they're still working to launch the
game on other platforms but it's taking
longer than they anticipated but if
you're like me then you probably don't
give a [__] about any of this to be
honest all I want to know is when a
replay feature is coming the game has
almost been out for three years